[Music]
anthony's going to start us off in los
angeles hi anthony welcome to the ramsay
show
hi how are you doing mr ramsay great man
what's up
um so my fiance and i recently got
engaged last august
and we've been fighting about the cost
of it i told her that i wanted to pay
off my debt first before we went and
tried to pay off a big wedding
and i just paid off my debt this month
and
with the wedding that she wants i can't
afford it with it only being six months
away and i've been telling her that i
don't know what is the price tag
sixteen thousand
the price tag is twenty thousand but she
we she paid six uh four thousand so
there's 16 left what do you make
about 30 40 a year
okay
what does she make
about the same sir we're both in the
military
oh actually okay
i'm sorry go ahead with your question
uh and that's basically
so i was telling her that i don't feel
comfortable going back in debt
um but she basically i asked her to move
it back she said if the wedding doesn't
happen when it's scheduled just like
that there's kind of no reason for us to
continue and i don't know if this is
something i should hold my ground on or
as a man
if i should make this happen for her
well the surface problem is that she's
choosing a wedding over you
which you're kind of involved in the
wedding so this is kind of oxymoronic
it's a little crazy
but then there's deeper st i mean i
would think though anthony there's other
stuff going on right i mean
is it that that that i mean do you have
a pattern of not doing what you say and
she feels like that this is part of it i
mean like is there is there other stuff
or is it really that simple that she's
like if i can't
have this wedding at this date with
twenty thousand dollars
i'm done like is it was it really that
cut and dry or have you guys been
uh we've been fighting uh since we got
engaged fighting about what about what
specifically for me it's the cost of it
she says that um
i'm being greedy and this is something
that
people
you know pay for
and i've just been telling her i just
don't feel comfortable going in debt
there's other ways around it i've said
if we can push it back which we've
already pushed it back it was originally
supposed to be uh happening next month
but due to our finances from coming back
overseas we pushed it that's so
frustrating i'm like go get a man go get
go go get married you guys have been
engaged for a year
go get a marriage certificate you guys
go to the courthouse go get married and
then in six months well yeah i guess
that's probably true i guess this would
have been like this is what i would want
for you though if it was in a healthy
state that's fair that's fair it's to go
do that and then you can go do a
reception another time but there's but
there are there are too many red flags
here let's establish a couple things all
right
a 16 000 wedding is not
too much
you're wrong that is a reasonably priced
wedding
and yes sir but you are right to say i'm
not willing to borrow money to do it and
i don't make a lot of money it's going
to take me a while to scratch that
together
so in in the sense that she's right she
probably
feels like you don't value her you don't
value the
ceremony
and you're not you know you don't
hey so or is being cheap yeah you're
being cheap when it comes to her and
that's probably hurting her feelings
that's probably where the fights are
coming from how old are you two
i'm 23 sir and she is 24 sir okay
all right so um the amount is not out of
line
the process and everything around the
thing is out of line
when you hear
uh if i don't get my wedding my way
i'm out of here well guess what you're
going to hear that the rest of your life
if i don't get this car i'm out of here
if i don't get this couch i'm out of
here if i don't if you don't budget for
my nails and my hair i'm out of here so
you know you're not an atm machine
you're a husband potentially
okay and it's not a matter of as a man
it's a matter of we need to be as two
grown-ups in uh in
uh agreement in alignment of how we're
gonna live our lives and if we can't
establish that i'm not gonna borrow
money
and so if you
if you demand that we do things that
require that we borrow money then we
don't need to get married because that's
going to be in inconsistent and we're
always going to be fighting and it's not
good it's going to lead to another
divorce or a divorce in the future so we
don't need to do that but if we can be
in agreement that
the amount is reasonable but the process
the ultimatum i'm out of here if i don't
get what i want spoiled little brat
routine
or the process of i demand you borrow
money to make me happy um and again
that's against your values then yeah
this is over
she needs to just check out
so uh so if i were in your shoes
obviously you guys are in love or you
think you are
um
i would try to sit down with a pastor a
chaplain you're in the military get a
chaplain to sit down with you uh a good
christian chaplain
um is the only way i know to get at it
um
so
or go see a pastor at a local church and
sit down and try to get some coaching
and some counseling some relational
input on how you guys deal with this it
sounds like you're talking at each other
instead of with each other
yes sir
like she's not hearing how important
this is to you and you're not hearing
how important this is to her
and so it comes down to
you have to borrow money to make me
happy that's probably not what she
really means
i hope she's not that immature and
shallow
she's probably just saying
dude this has been going on forever
you know it's been going on forever and
i don't see how we're ever going to get
there and i can't you know if we don't
borrow money i don't know how we're
going to have sixteen thousand dollars i
don't know how we're gonna have a decent
wedding but a sixteen thousand dollar
wedding with both of you working and
household income would be the equivalent
of about seventy thousand is not
unreasonable yeah
it's not if you have the cash and can
put the cash together
um by the way during this year while you
were getting out of debt she put a whole
four thousand dollars towards this
where's her
if she makes the same amount of money
uh it's not your obligation to man up i
mean you're over here cleaning up
something else yeah so and i don't
necessarily believe you have to be out
of debt to be married either by the way
that's another thing i would throw at
you so we do want you to live out of
debt and debt free because we believe
that's the best way you're going to have
a great life
but it's not yeah you're not required to
be debt free to start a fan have a baby
or get married like these big life
things but you do need to be in
agreement and right now the big the big
red flags are you're not in agreement
and if this does come down to the
ultimatum of
you either borrow money
or i'm out of here
then you know
i'm gonna miss her
gonna miss you
that's what it comes down to
she's walking away yeah the whole
country song
allen jackson
no brad paisley no oh
brad paisley is a fishing song yeah i'm
going to miss her too yeah there's a lot
anthony yeah this is the ramsay show